>> THE ULTIMATE GAME CHANGER AND
THIS WILL BE A VACCINE.
CERTAINLY A VACCINE WITH OTHER
DISEASES THAT WITH SCOURGES IN
THE PAST WE DON’T EVEN WORRY
ABOUT.
>> Bill: JOHNSON & JOHNSON
WORKING ON A VACCINE THAT COULD
BE AVAILABLE MAY BE THE FALL.
JOHNSON & JOHNSON, GIVE US A
STATUS FOR YOUR TRIAL IN THE
LAB.
READY TO STAND AS OF NOW?
>> WE STARTED A GENERAL READ OF
THE VACCINE IN THE LABORATORY,
AND SO TODAY WE SELECTED OUR
LEAD CANDIDATE EARLIER THIS WEEK
AND I WE START DOING THE
PRECLINICAL WORK.
WE NEED TO BE ABLE START COUNT
CLINICAL TRIALS EARLY SEPTEMBER.
WE START AND ARE ABLE TO EXPAND
IT TO EMERGENCY USE CIRCUMSTANCE
CIRCUMSTANCE.
>> Bill: WHAT WERE USING IN IN
THIS VACCINE THEN?
>> WE STARTED WHEN WE RECEIVED
THE CODE TO, THE CODE WAS
PUBLISHED OF THE SEQUENCE OF THE
VIRUS BY THE CHINESE AND THAT
GIVE US THE INFORMATION ON HOW
THE VIRUS LOOKED LIKE.
FROM THE CODE ON PAPER, AND WE
HAVE AN EXISTING VACCINE
PLATFORM WHICH WE HAVE USED IN
HIV AND IN ORDER TO TREAT EBOLA
AND SICA SO WE USED THE SAME
PLATFORM WHICH IS A VECTOR THAT
WE USE, WE CAN CONSTRUCTED THE
VECTOR AND NOW TEN WEEKS LATER
WE ARE ABLE TO SELECT A VACCINE
WHICH WE CAN BRING FORWARD INTO
CLINICAL TRIALS IN SEPTEMBER.
>> Bill: A VERY TECHNICAL
QUESTION, WHAT WAS THE DAY THAT
THE CHINESE PROVIDED THIS
VACCINE FOR YOU?
DO YOU RECALL THAT?
>> NOT EXACTLY.
I KNOW WHEN IT WAS PUBLISHED AND
AT THAT MOMENT WE WERE ABLE BUT
IT WAS EARLY IN JANUARY.
NOT SO MUCH LATER WE HAD
PATIENTS IN EUROPE AND ALSO THE
U.S. AND WE WERE ABLE TO GET THE
VACCINE, THE LIVE VACCINE OUT OF
THE PATIENTS WHO WERE ON THE
GROUND IN EUROPE AND THE U.S. TO
CONTINUE TO WORK ON IT.
SO VERY QUICKLY WE WERE ABLE TO
FURTHER IDENTIFY THE VIRUS.
BUT WE STARTED WITH THE CODE
THAT THE CHINESE PUBLISHED, THE
GENETIC CODE.
>> Bill: YOU’VE WORKED ON HIV
AND EBOLA IN YEARS PAST, WHAT’S
DIFFERENT WITH KOVIC 19 THAT YOU
HAVE FILED?
FOUND?
>> KOVIC 19 IS EXTERNALLY FAST
SPREADING.
WE WORKED ON SARS, THEN STARTED
WORKING ON A VACCINE BUT SARS
DISAPPEARED.
THIS VIRUS NOW IS LESS LETHAL
THAN SARS BUT SO MUCH MORE
SPREADING THAT IT CAUSES SO MANY
MORE DATA BECAUSE IT’S AFFECTING
THE POPULATION WORLDWIDE.
AND THAT IS WHY -- THAT IS WHY
WHEN WE STARTED THE DEVELOPMENT
OF THE VACCINE WE HAVE TO
IMMEDIATELY GET GOING ON
MANUFACTURING BECAUSE WE NEED TO
HAVE HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF
VACCINES AVAILABLE WHEN WE COME
UP WITH THE CLINICAL DATA.
THAT’S WHY WE STARTED INVESTING
IMMEDIATELY IN ADDITIONAL SITES
AND WE KICK OFF THE
MANUFACTURING NOW FULLY AT RISK.
AS YOU KNOW WE HAVE MADE A
COLLABORATION WITH THE U.S.
GOVERNMENT AND TOGETHER
INVESTING $1 BILLION IN THE
OBJECTIVE NOW IS PREPARING
EVERYTHING TO BE ABLE TO PRODUCE
1 BILLION VACCINES NEXT YEAR.
>> Bill: THE WORLD IS PULLING
FOR YOU.
ONCE YOU START TESTING ON HUMANS
HOW LONG BEFORE YOU KNOW, WE GOT
IT?
>> WELL IT WILL PROBABLY TAKE
FOUR OR FIVE MONTHS DEPENDING ON
WHERE IN THE WORLD THE INFECTION
IS STILL ONGOING, SO THAT WE CAN
DO CLINICAL TRIALS FAST.
WE NEED FOUR OR FIVE MONTHS TO
GET THERE CLINICAL RESULTS IN
ORDER TO START VACCINATING
PEOPLE.
>> Bill: ONWARD, YOU ARE A
GREAT GUEST AND THANKS FOR